today we're going to talk about
where all the elements came from here's
a periodic table of all the elements and
make up
everything that we see around us so the
iron in your blood the gold in my
wedding ring silicon in your camera
where does all that come from
and in telling that story we're going to
go we're going to start at the big bang
and we're going to look at how the
elements are cooked up in stars and in
exploding stars and how they're
distributed throughout the
galaxy so most of the ordinary
atoms that we see in the universe are
actually hydrogen and helium 75 is
hydrogen and about a quarter of helium
and everything else only makes up about
two percent of all the ordinary stuff in
the universe
and we think hydrogen helium were
primordial by which you mean they were
made in the big bang so what about all
of the all the other elements well we
believe those are cooked up in stars
and this is something that we've only
really known for about a hundred years
of course the origin of the elements
have been a mystery for millennia
but we now from observations made in
astronomy think we have a consistent
picture for where all the elements came
from
so uh how are stars powered i mean this
has been a mystery for for a long time
it was actually arthur eddington in in
1920s i believe who first suggested that
stars might be powered by nuclear fusion
so hydrogen atoms fusing together to
make helium and when in doing so they
release an enormous amount of energy
uh and this is how we believe most
ordinary stars are powered throughout
their lifetime so our own sun all the
energy the light the power we see from
our sun
is produced by hydrogen atoms fusing
together to form helium
but in about four or five billion years
the core of our sun will run out of
hydrogen
and it will form a core of helium and at
that point
the fusion reactions will stop the core
will contract to form what we call a
white dwarf star
and basically the sun will die
but what happens in more massive stars
is very very interesting is in the more
massive stars that we think
helium can be fused together to form the
heavier elements so in a very massive
star for example when it runs out of
hydrogen in the core
the core will contract all that stuff
will compress down and start fusing the
helium atoms together to form for
example carbon
and this process continues the coral
collapse and crunch down a bit more and
then it'll start to cook up heavier
elements like silicon and oxygen so
here's a picture of what you end up with
in the core of a massive star
so you end up with layers kind of
onion-like layers of hydrogen burning
helium burning a shell of carbon or
oxygen and silicon but then something
catastrophic happens when you start to
have a dense core of iron
and iron's crucial in this process
because when you try to fuse things with
iron it actually takes in more energy
than it gives out by nuclear fusion
so when you get a dense core of iron
formed something catastrophic happens
the core is no longer producing the
outward thermal pressure
gravity is still compressing things in
and so you get a catastrophic collapse
of the star the core will collapse from
perhaps a region the size of the earth
down to a dense ball of neutrons we call
a neutron star that's maybe only 10
kilometers across
and so this is an enormous amount of
gravitational energy is released in this
collapse and it's the bounce back
effectively from this dense neutron star
core that produces a supernova explosion
the shock wave then disrupts the rest of
the star this enormous amount of
gravitational energy is released
and the outer regions of the star blown
off into space in a powerful supernova
explosion so in that supernova explosion
that's when we believe
the heavier elements were formed so all
the elements up to iron are formed
either in a big bang or being cooked up
in massive stars but in that enormous
supernova explosion that's when we
believe the heavier elements are formed
so elements like like gold in my wedding
room uh like arsenic uranium hydrogen
and helium are basically
primordial form in the first 20 minutes
of the big bang
the elements carbon up to iron are
basically cooked up in the core of
massive stars and these onion-like
shells and then the heavier elements are
produced when a star dies in its death
throes in the supernova explosion
so brady uh what we're seeing here is uh
what's left over from a supernova
explosion so this is a uh the cassay
supernova remnant that was observed to
explode on earth uh in 1680 or
thereabouts
um and what we're seeing here is a
multi-color image produced by combining
infrared data from the spitzer space
telescope optical data in green from the
hubble space telescope and the blue
stuff are x-rays from the chandra x-ray
space telescope so and what we're seeing
there is the the remnant from the
supernova as it heats material as it
plows out through the interstellar
medium so what's going on here is that
the elements that are cooked up in the
star and heavy elements that are
produced in the supernova explosion
itself are being distributed throughout
the galaxy
so this shockwave from the supernova
spreads out at velocities of tens of
thousands of kilometers per second and
it spreads out all of these
all of these elements throughout the
galaxy
and i'm going to show you another one
this is the crab supernova remnant this
was observed to explode in 1054
although it actually exploded much uh
actually exploded more like six thousand
years ago because it's actually at a
distance of six and a half thousand
light years so at the center of this
incredible remnant it was actually a
pulsar there's the remnant neutron star
left over from that supernova explosion
there's an object in there spinning at
about 30 times a second and that's the
remnant core of this supernova explosion
that thing is about so this is about 12
light years across so in just a thousand
years essentially this thing has spread
out so
uh over an incredible distance to travel
at a speed of light it'll take you 12
years to get from one side to the other